shall we should we start no ladies first
no say it because i think it sounds
really nice with your accent well i'll
talk audio
yeah archweal audio i mean really
shall we yeah let's do it well i don't
think anyone really knows what the
royals think about the podcast we know
what the
majority of the public think and they
didn't think a huge amount it didn't
rate
as the number one podcast i think it it
came relatively low down on spotify's
top 20 list however as far as the couple
are concerned
it it hit the right note it put them out
in a way where
they clearly want to be established and
welcome to
archwell audio no he has a podcast voice
this was really the first we'd heard
from harry and megan together
i think it was very authentic i think it
it was very them
and it really sets the tone for what
they want to do so i don't think they're
going to be too bothered
that it only ranked 13. i mean they
managed to get sir elton john
on their first podcast that's pretty
impressive and my understanding
uh is that they're very pleased with how
it's gone we don't know when we're going
to get the next podcast
after me ready happy happy
new new year
possibly it won't be harry and megan
hosting it the next time this was a
one-off
holiday special but certainly archwell
audio as we've seen from their newly
launched website
is going to be a key part of what
they're doing with archwell
so i think when you look back at what
has been a really challenging year for
everyone but also for megan and harry
actually they have emerged as winners
they
they sealed the deal with netflix with
spotify
they launched their new website all by
the end of the year
we heard more of the real them i think
than perhaps we've ever heard
in their holiday podcast special and so
i think that
marked the close of 2020 on a high for
them
this is a year where harry has
communicated on a regular basis
with his grandmother i think the general
feeling is that
the couple are sticking to the terms of
the agreement
everything that they are doing is very
much in keeping with that tone of
respect towards the establishment and
the monarchy but the general consensus
is that this divorce has worked
megan and harry left the royal family to
become independent to become
financially independent they have
absolutely achieved that this year they
have set themselves up for what looks
set to be
an exciting future
you